polkas clashed with the Avengers
countless times but usually it's out of
love
Earth's Mightiest Heroes are often just
trying to protect innocent people from
Hulk's rampages fair enough
but sometimes the Avengers could just be
super jerks to the green Goliath while
Hulk was technically one of the original
Avengers in 1963's Avengers number one
the group's founding was largely a hunt
for the man monster much like the movie
adaptation Avengers number one saw Loki
accidentally forming the Avengers while
trying to use Hulk to defeat his
half-brother Thor when Loki shows up The
Hulk is in hiding acting as a performer
in a circus later when the Hulk uses his
colossal strength to save a train on a
broken track Loki uses his illusions to
make it appear the Hulk was the culprit
who wrecked the tracks in the first
place
Rick Jones and his team Brigade call out
with ham radios to any heroes who could
help stem the Hulk's threat an Iron Man
ant-man and the wasp answer the three
soon to be teammates spend most of
Avengers number one chasing the Hulk and
battling him in a factory before anyone
gets seriously hurt Thor arrives with
Loki as his prisoner having figured out
Loki scheme while the now iconic cover
of Avengers number 1 depicts the five
original Avengers battling Loki the only
one who truly threw down with him was
Thor the Hulk did nothing but fight off
his attackers who believe the lie that
the Hulk was nothing more than a
rampaging beast the Hulk's time in the
Avengers was short-lived
he quit at the end of Avengers number
two and considering everything it's
tough to blame him in Avengers number
two the team was infiltrated by an alien
villain named the space phantom who
could mimic the appearance of different
heroes unsurprisingly he chose the Hulk
as his victim and used the giant green
monster to beat up the Avengers a bit
before switching into a different body
when the smoke cleared and everyone
realized what had happened the Hulk was
angry of what the Avengers said about
him when they believed they were
fighting him Hulk I love you one of the
Avengers one of a team one of one of our
friends is what friends do they support
each other that could have been the end
of it but in Avengers number three the
Avengers actively hunted the Hulk and
battled him once more the Hulk fought
them off and eventually allied himself
with the aquatic outcasts Namor the
Submariner in an attempt to destroy the
team and get them off his back
in 1988 the High Evolutionary was
ticking off the whole Marvel Universe
and an event called evolutionary war
which ran through Marvel's annuals the
finale was in Avengers annual number 17
but there was a problem The Avengers had
disbanded an alarm summoned a band of
reserved Avengers anyway at the end of
Incredible Hulk number 350 Hulk is
finishing an epic battle with the thing
of the Fantastic Four
when x-men's beast happens upon the Hulk
and strong arms him into helping the
Avengers at the time most of the world
believed the Hulk had died in a gamma
bomb explosion a few issues earlier
except he didn't instead a gray more
intelligent version of the Hulk had
survived and relocated to Las Vegas man
he liked the world thinking he was dead
so the Beast did exactly what any
honorable heroic member of the Avengers
and the x-men would do he told the Hulk
if he didn't help the Avengers he'd
revealed to the entire world that he was
still alive
making him a wanted man monster once
more how heroic it's no secret the Hulk
tends to hold a grudge but in Marvel
Comics the Hulk isn't the only one who
knows how to hold on to a beef in 1995's
Incredible Hulk number 434 the Avengers
threw the first punch the issue
immediately followed the over the edge
event in which Nick Fury has been killed
and the Avengers blame the Hulk for
Fury's death as soon as the Hulk shows
up to the funeral The Avengers attack
him it was even the usually rational
Android vision who starts everything by
using his phasing powers to shove his
finger into the Hulk's brain somewhat
surprisingly the Hulk hardly fights back
uncharacteristically trying to talk his
way out of a fight when the Avengers
lock horns with the Hulk in 1986 is
Incredible Hulk number 316 they battle a
different kind of hole the gamma-powered
hero doc Samson has developed a method
to physically separate Bruce Banner from
his greener hat as a result and utterly
mindless Hulk was raging through the New
Mexico desert destroying everything who
saw that leads the Avengers to send
therefore physically strongest members
Hercules Namor Wonder Man and Iron Man
to stop him it makes sense the Avengers
would want to take out such a
destructive version of the green Goliath
but half of the quartet formed in the
desert to tussle
the Hulk don't even bother to take it
seriously wonder man acts like the
pampered Hollywood socialite that he was
at the time and Hercules in particular
treats the whole thing like a game that
wouldn't be the last time that the
Avengers attacked the hole to prevent
untold destruction during Civil War to
the inhuman Ulysses psychic vision shows
the original Hulk on a rampage
apparently murdering most of Marvel's
heroes when those heroes confront Banner
they discover he's researching gamma
radiation and are less than happy with
the implications a huge group of heroes
confront Banner because the best thing
you can do to someone with anger issues
is surround him with as many people as
possible while yelling at him clearly
your friend is in desperate need of help
we realized we also just need as many
people attacking this guy as we can
possibly get before anything can be
resolved Hawkeye murders Bruce Banner
sort of a flashback reveals that banner
had actually created the arrows that
Clint Barton used to kill him and that
he had given them to the archer in case
he should ever need to be put down
Hawkeye claims he saw banners eyes flash
green before he fired off the fatal shot
but whether or not that was true is left
purposely ambiguous while the Avengers
and Hulk were both stinging from a
couple of recent clashes
Earth's Mightiest and the Hulk were
forced to work together for the Marvel
wide comics event onslaught while things
never got violent between Hulk and his
former teammates it wasn't for lack of
the Avengers trying an Incredible Hulk
number 4:45 The Hulk gets so tired of
the Avengers giving him dirty looks
everywhere he went that he tells them so
in spite of Hulk telling them to stop
unless they want him to join the other
side the heroes continue to look at him
like they would love nothing more than
for the green Goliath to try something
by the way treating the Hulk like
garbage during onslaught wasn't just an
Avengers game after the event finale an
onslaught Marvel Universe number 1 when
the Hulk provided the decisive blow
against onslaught by cracking the
villains supposedly impenetrable armor
the Avengers and the Fantastic Four
disappear and are presumed dead The Hulk
is left lying on the ground and the
x-men just leave him there they don't
even mention it without him onslaught
would have won but the heroes don't seem
to care not all of the Avengers
unwarranted assaults on the Hulk
occurred in Marvel's heyday as recently
as 2018
immortal hope number six ends with the
Avengers tracking down the newly
resurrected Bruce Banner to capture him
one of the biggest reasons for their
attack was a battle between the Hulk and
the Canadian hero Sasquatch in a
hospital immortal Hulk number 7 opens
with every indication that the Avengers
are not going to get their way the whole
crews more powerful than ever
hitting Thor so hard that Captain
America has to carry him from the
battlefield The Hulk rips up yet another
Hulkbuster armor to pieces and takes out
his cousin she-hulk with a single punch
unfortunately for Hulk Black Panther and
Tony Stark have a powerful energy cannon
orbiting the earth ready to take him out
if the Avengers can't do it themselves
unable to stop him any other way the
Avengers kill the Hulk with the cannon
knowing that he'll come back since he
always does comics aren't the only
medium in which the Avengers treat the
Hulk like trash
sure usually in the movies when the halt
clashes with his teammates he's the one
to initiate the throwdown so it's hard
to blame them but what about a scene
that isn't a fight what about a scene
that was an audience pleaser in the
theaters towards the end of Avengers age
of Ultron after Bruce Banner frees Black
Widow from Ultron's prison he's ready to
go with Widow's idea to skedaddle and
live on the run with her he doesn't seem
at all scared of helping the Avengers
fight Ultron at least not for himself
but the last time he transformed it was
under the scarlet witch's influence and
he ended up going on a deadly rampage
it's something he doesn't want to repeat
Black Widow takes the choice out of
banners hands she pushes him off a ledge
forcing him to transform into the Hulk
to save himself why I need the other guy
let's finish the job it may have gotten
applause in the theater but considering
how close Bruce and Natasha had grown
and how harrowing and experience it is
for banner to transform into the Hulk
and back Widow's pushes a chilling
betrayal no Asgardian hammer or titanium
fist could wound him more and of course
who could forget Planet Hulk in 2005
Bruce Banner agrees to help shield take
out a dangerous space-based Hydra weapon
unfortunately it's a trap
while the Hydra threat was presumably
real the primary purpose of Hulk's
recruitment was to get him into space
once he completes the mission and boards
the shuttle that he thought would take
him home the ship heads off in a
different direction and a recorded
message plays for members of Marvel's
Illuminati mr. fantastic Iron Man
Doctor Strange and Black Bolt appear
before Hulk explaining to him that they
are sending him away both for his own
good and bad of Earth the betrayal leads
to one of the most memorable and
well-loved Hulk stories of recent memory
Planet Hulk that storyline also leads to
the follow-up revenge story 2007's world
war hulk which sees the hulk smash all
four of his betrayers as well as a
healthy chunk of the rest of marvel's
heroes at the end of the day there's one
thing you can always count on Hulk to do
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorites topper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you